it is video tracking a killer on the way
to committing mass murder 28 year old
Audrey Hale shoots through locked doors
at the entrance to Covenant School Hale
a biological woman who identified as a
man stalks the corridors as a former
student the shooter knows and has
studied the layout of this building as
an alarm goes off hail moves from room
to room looking for pupils or staff who
are hiding in fear over the course of 14
minutes inside they murder three
children and three adults armed police
shot dead hail after an exchange of fire
during which the window of a patrol car
is shot out
one of those killed was 60 year old head
teacher Catherine Kuntz the caretaker
Mike Hill whose brother and nephew also
work at the school was murdered too Hale
who had no criminal record had left
behind a Manifesto
there were Maps drawn of the school in
detail of surveillance entry points Etc
people came through the night to pay
their respects some worried about the
potential this attack has to stir hate
and reprisals here
unfortunately is going to have a ripple
effect through the trans community and
that's very sad it's hard enough and
dangerous enough normally for anyone
who's in that community and
um
fortunately I think it's just going to
be worse this is the
129th mass shooting that's one with four
or more victims in the United States
just this year what marks this event out
is the identity of the shooter and the
age of the victims but it is a
continuation of America's never-ending
cycle of gun violence
everyone here hopes it will not happen
to their school their supermarket their
City this is Nashville's tragedy the
latest but almost certainly not the last
Martha Kellner Sky News Nashville